Riley: The world’s oceans make up the
largest habitat on the planet.
And they contain one of our most
vital sources of food.
Fish.
And we eat a lot of it.
The average human being consumes
around 45 pounds of fish every year.
And for over 3 billion people, it's
their primary source of protein.
Global demand for seafood is
rising, fuelling a multibillion-dollar
commercial fishing industry.
But experts warn that in some
places, these commercial vessels
are catching more fish than the
ocean can provide,
threatening sea life, and the very
people who rely on the ocean the most.
According to the United Nations,
there are over 370 million
indigenous people around the world.
Along the world's coastlines, there
are more than 27 million indigenous
people spread across at
least 87 countries.
And for many of these coastal
communities, the ocean has been
vital to their culture and survival
for 1000s of years.
Andrés: So coastal indigenous
peoples is a group that really
encompasses a lot of different
types of communities, sometimes
entire nations.
It's something that's not an
official definition. It's something
that we use sort of as a shorthand
for indigenous communities that
still live on coastlines.
One defining aspect that we see
again and again, is an incredibly
close relationship with seafood.
Just the practice of fishing has a
lot of cultural significance, right.
So even though, yes, they
rely a lot on fish for local food
security and nutrition,
even just the practice of going out
is a way in which they share
stories, communicate knowledge and
really kind of further their traditions.
Marilyn: The Heiltsuk Nation is one
of the largest tribes on the
Central Coast.
We are a marine community. We're
located, you know, right, you know,
the ocean is right in front of us.
We live in a really remote area,
and it's very isolated. And it's
very costly to get, you know,
groceries up here.
So our sustenance and our way of
life has been to harvest salmon,
spawn on kelp, crabs,
prawns, seaweed.
Our breadbasket is the ocean.
Dresy: Typically a Vezo is a man or
woman, but mostly men who go
fishing using the traditional canoe
and who live mainly on fishing.
The Vezo has been there for centuries.
and they've been transmitting their
techniques from generation to generation.
The sea is, for the Vezo, I think,
the main source of livelihoods and
also income for the family.
The simplest one will use the
simplest gears.
That could be spears and maybe
pulling line, while the rich ones
can go and buy nets and they'll be
using those nets.
Depending on where they are on the
coastline, they can catch like
octopus around the reef. Also, they
can catch squid, tuna, lobster.
Mostly they're catching
small pelagic fish.
Riley: Today, coastal indigenous
people consume around 15 times more
fish than non-indigenous people.
And many rely heavily on seafood
as a source of income.
But in recent years, they've been forced
to compete with large scale commercial
fishing vessels capable of catching
several tons of fish per day.
Andrés: Commercial fisheries, at an
industrial scale, are relatively
recent, right.
Obviously, we've been fishing for a
long, long time, but when we really
see fisheries sort of globally,
ramp up is, you know, from the 1950s.
Narrator: British Columbia home,
the world's largest salmon fleets,
hits the fisherman's jackpot.
A $5 million catch.
Nets one third of a mile long are
dropped around a school of fish and
the hauling in begins.
Andrés: There's really two
different main kinds. One is the
national industrial vessels, right
so a lot of countries have their
national commercial fishing fleets.
And that often is kind of the first
source of conflict right, you have
these larger boats, they're
operating locally, but they have
much more capacity than what
indigenous communities have right
and so that's a big source of
competition.
Another one that's relatively more
recent are distant water fisheries.
These are primarily from
Eastern Asia, Western Europe.
These are fleets that go all over
the world. And they have enormous
impacts not only for indigenous
peoples, but also for just the
countries where they're operating.
Probably the most direct way that
this has impacted is obviously
through overfishing of their shared
stocks, but also through crowding
out of what used to be traditional
indigenous areas, places where we
saw these traditional area-based
protections or particular rules
about when to fish and how and what.
A lot of these commercial vessels
don't have any respect for that
sort of thing. And so that has
caused a lot of conflict and
tension.
Riley: According to a United Nations report,
While estimates vary, it's believed
that around one in every five fish
sold are caught by vessels engaged
in illegal, unreported and
unregulated fishing activity each year.
Rachel: There's a significant
amount of noncompliance out there
globally, and not just distant
water fleets, just generally
throughout the fishing industry.
You could have minor offenses up to
what we call serious infringements.
A minor offense could be
a mistake on a logbook,
up to a serious infringement, we could
be significant fishing over quota,
without a license, without
authorization.
And those are generally the dark
vessels that we talk about, which
can do significant damage and harm.
Penalties and sanctions for
fisheries offenses can generally
tend to be quite low.
And if you're making millions and
millions of pounds in illegal
fishing, it's worth breaking the
law. And there are some organized
fisheries crime syndicates that
will factor these types of fines
into their activity, almost
as if it's a business cost.
Riley: Many of these vessels use a
variety of techniques to skirt the
law and avoid detection.
But modern technology is helping
governments and coastal communities
protect their waters from
this type of fishing.
Rachel: So this is done through the
use of remote sensing, so satellite
technology.
We use a varying range of sensors
with a different degree of
resolution. And they help us to
detect vessels that either fish at
night by detecting their lights or
fishing during the day.
And we can task and focus these
satellites in areas of interest.
The intelligence information that
comes from that is then given to
our partners in government, and
they use that to task their patrols
and surveillance at sea for
fisheries enforcement.
One of the problems with vessels on
the high seas is that they're
technically a piece of that
nation's land at sea.
Let's just say it's a Madagascar
flagged vessel, and it's a UK
fisheries protection vessel, you
would need to get permission from
the Madagascan authorities to board
that vessel in high seas.
And so some of the techniques are a
constant changing of flag, which
means that you never know which
nation you're supposed to be asking
permission, or you'll go to one and
it turns out, they've moved to
another at which point you're
running out of fuel, you've got to
go, you're hundreds of miles from land.
The true dark vessels, the IUU
vessels will use fixers in ports
so they can land their illegal catches.
We see all sorts so misreporting of
catches; I say I caught it here and
then we've actually seen them
fishing somewhere completely differently.
We see it a lot on boundaries, a
territorial waters boundary, for
example, but also on marine
protected areas.
There are buffer zones around
marine protected areas, and you
will see a vessel sitting right on
the outside of that pointing in a
certain direction that you can be
pretty confident that the net is
probably inside the area.
Often the key thing is they will
switch off their tracking system.
So this is the AIS, the Automatic
Identification System,
or they'll spoof, so they can put
another vessel’s AIS system on their
vessel, or they can actually name
themselves something completely
different.
It's not necessarily that these
vessels are not licensed or
authorized. And there have been
some countries in the past that
have made a significant amount of
money from opening up their
licenses.
And so there are various states,
flags of convenience they're
called, which will open up their
licenses and their waters to these
vessels without consideration of
the smaller communities that rely
on the water and the fish.
Andrés: The reason that a lot of
these fisheries, the distant water
fisheries, are able to operate far
from their home ports is because of
government subsidies.
These are government's paying for
fuel, for bigger boats, for
maintenance.
There was one recent study that
found that if you took those
subsidies away, about 50% of those
distant water fleets wouldn't be
profitable.
Rachel: Most countries, if not all
countries subsidize their fisheries in some way.
There will be fishing vessels that
will be fishing in a noncompliant
manner that are in receipt of subsidies.
Dresy: There are signs of overexploitation.
Dresy: We have testimony from the
Vezo people saying that, you know,
once those big vessels are around,
there's no more left to fish, and
they are forced to go further
offshore, which is quite dangerous
for the Vezo.
The trawlers are destroying the
habitats. They are destroying the
coral reef, dragging all around and
with the fish.
It's quite difficult to provide a
certain estimate of what they've
been losing, but what we hear from
the elder is that there used to be
bigger size of catch in terms of
fish. And now it's less and less,
and most of the catch today is very small.
There's a big impact for the Vezo,
especially on the livelihoods and
the food security issue.
Marilyn: You know, some of our
elders have talked about going out
on to the fishing grounds that
there are so many boats out on the
fishing grounds, at night time it
looked like a virtual city
out on the ocean.
Our communities can no longer
access salmon as a reliable and
abundant food source.
We do a lot of our own research here.
Our nation has experienced a
decline up to 85% in the salmon,
and that has had devastating
effects, you know, on our community.
We attribute this decline to
fishing. And that includes sports
and recreational. It also includes
other human activities as well.
That, you know, includes the
effects of climate change.
We really feel that, you know,
we're, you know, 10, 20 years
beyond a crisis.
Riley: We reached out to Canada's
Department of Fisheries and Oceans
for comment on this story.
They're aware of the significant
decline in salmon along the Central
Coast, and have launched a $647.1
million effort to stabilize and
rebuild stocks.
Here's what they said.
As coastal indigenous communities
try to combat overfishing,
they’re also dealing with the issue of
climate change. And these two
issues are deeply intertwined.
Andrés: One of the big dangers when
you combine overfishing and climate
change impacts on coastal indigenous communities is that,
you know, these ways of life
will be lost for good.
You know, on the one hand, you have
these very, very large, very
globalized commercial fishing
fleets that are just following fish
wherever they're moving to.
And then you have these habitat
impacts of climate change.
Rachel: We're messing with food
chains, we're messing with
habitats, we are releasing so much
gas into the atmosphere.
And now we're starting to see
significant impacts on our oceans,
we're starting to see reductions
in fish stocks.
Andrés: You get impacts on
mangroves, on coral reefs, on sea ice.
And those are places where
indigenous peoples
disproportionately live around the world.
In a lot of places, just because of
colonial histories, many of these
indigenous peoples' rights
are tied to places.
They're even kind of legally, in
some ways, bound to the place where
they are. And so it's very
difficult for them to leave.
You know, when people aren't able
to fish, they have to move
outside of their communities, it
doesn't take long for the language
to be lost, for the
knowledge to be lost.
And that is a loss of culture.
Marilyn: It's a part of our DNA,
it's part of who we are. And if we
cannot access that, we will lose
part of that identity of what we
have, which has sustained us
since time immemorial.
Dresy: What the Vezo will do is to
adapt themselves on the changing
environment. That's why they need
support from every stakeholder
to ensure that they can
keep their activities.
Andrés: Any of the things that we
can do to help starts with granting
them more sovereignty over their
resources, granting them the power
to decide what they're using,
how they're using it.
Vatosoa: We need to make sure that
small scale fishers, local
communities are involved and
consulted in big decisions, in high
level decisions regarding fishing
agreements or national policy.
There is the concept of locally
managed marine areas, which is a
concept that was developed in the
Pacific in the 90s.
One of the biggest issues of the
LMMA managers in Madagascar is the
fact that they are issolated, they
are marginalized, they do not have
any means of communication.
So that is the reason why those
small scale fishers took the
decision to create the national
network in 2012.
Dresy: Currently, it's around 200 and
more communities around the islands.
This is to help all those
communities to join their voice and
to be heard.
Andrés: At that point they become a
legally recognized player in the
management table. And that's been
something that hasn't happened
historically. And it's at the root
of a lot of these issues.
I do believe that commercial
fishing can coexist with
traditional indigenous ways of
life. And actually, a lot of
indigenous communities are fully
engaged with commercial fishing.
They're doing it themselves.
I think the important thing is that
we address the power imbalance that
very often is at play between
commercial fishing interests
and those of indigenous peoples.